Here's what nobody tells you about
mental strength. The people who truly
intimidate others aren't the loudest
ones in the room. They're the ones who
remain completely calm when everyone
else is losing their minds. But here's
the kicker. Mental strength isn't about
being tough. It's about being
anti-fragile. It's not about never
feeling fear. It's about dancing with
fear until it becomes your partner
instead of your enemy. Everyone wants to
be mentally strong until it's time to do
mentally strong things. We'll spend 20
minutes choosing what to watch on
Netflix, but won't invest 20 minutes
building the mental resilience that
could change our entire lives. Here's
your first reality check. Your mind is
either getting stronger or weaker every
single day. There's no neutral. Every
challenge you avoid makes you weaker.
Every difficult conversation you have
makes you stronger. The secret sauce,
instead of avoiding discomfort, you
systematically expose yourself to
controlled doses of it. Think of it as
building immunity. But for challenges,
start ridiculously small. Take cold
showers for 30 seconds. Have one
uncomfortable conversation per day.
Choose one small discomfort and face it
daily for a week. Watch what happens
when you stop being reactive and start
being responsive. When you stop
defending your worth and start embodying
it, when you build a mind so strong that
your presence naturally commands
respect, the only thing scarier than
having a weak mind is knowing you could
have built a strong one but chose not
to. Start today.